Ron Jaworski the former Eagles
quarterback ESPN NFL analyst and now
works for the NFL Network NFL Films film
sessions and he joins us now can you
believe that Jones would you ever do
that if you could make the cut at a PGA
Tour event and then miss your weekend
assignment yes I would I love the golf
club by nine point five index he's not
gonna be calling a game if he makes the
cut I chuckle I would not do that I
think you gotta commit and then you have
to live up here commit your your real
job all right
what do you take away from last night's
game yeah a very entertaining game
obviously I actually did I predicted the
Eagles would win the game 2820 and I
felt basically they would win because
they're strong in the trenches and as
you know you look at teams that are
consistent and playoff contenders you
know they're strong on the offensive
defensive line and going into that game
I thought the Packers will knurl in the
running game and and certainly you know
the Eagles offensive line did a really
good job in that regard so that was
really critical then you know they also
did get the injury factor and but you
know everyone seems to be banged up
right now but I felt they'd win the game
I ate look I did not expect Aaron
Rodgers to light it up like he did but
I'm not surprised by that but they had
become more of a defensive oriented
balanced team so I did not expect
Rodgers to have that big night but he is
he's an incredible incredible
quarterback okay the play calling I I
don't want to scrutinize it too much
because if I don't know it feels like
Aaron Rodgers could accidentally have
scored a touchdown down there on the
goal line with four downs what do you
think of the play calling yeah I think
what happened is you know Matt Lafleur
gave up on the running game they they
were not running the football I mean
when Aaron Rodgers your leading rusher
and they're you know they're not running
the ball weren't worth a lick so there's
there have no problem with putting the
ball in a future hall-of-famer and Aaron
Rodgers but then you now have a depleted
receiving corps as well which makes it
even tougher but it just goes to show
you you know it's not it's not how many
times you run the football it's
when you run it and when you run it
effectively and they just didn't run the
football effectively and it cost him
yeah I wasn't quite sure I know there
were a couple of run pass options in
there and I think Philadelphia did a
really good job on a couple of those
plays I thought that you know they he
was gonna bootleg and walk into the end
zone I think he thought that he was
gonna fake that handoff and just bootleg
into the end zone but I give the Eagles
a lot of credit that's not a great
secondary right now and you know it was
kind of bend but don't break no no
question and it certainly was that the
RPO but it did I thought what Aaron rod
Aaron Rodgers got in the edge you won't
score but the the secondary Eagles you
know played very very sound they didn't
bite the fake and it was I didn't get my
game film download yet so I really don't
know but it looked like the wide
receivers were kind of confused Jimmy
Graham was you know kind of blocking and
in the no I don't know it was far off to
the left but he was kind of blocking it
didn't seem like it was it was an RPO
with the run-pass option when the
receivers weren't running routes yeah so
I I didn't get a chance to evaluate that
yet but it was a strange play pass
interference I I hate the fact that
they've changed this rule Jones because
all it was was just one bad call in a
game and I didn't think they needed to
overhaul this plus you can't review in
the last two minutes you can't challenge
that so that's where that's the only
time I would want pass interference
reviewed there was one last night where
I went okay that's pass interference on
the Eagles and then they didn't call it
so I'm confused here help me out I'm
with you and I hate the rule and when it
was first put in you know during
training camp I hate it I said it's
gonna cause more problems you know and
it seems to have gone that way
you you know the NFL is trying to
legislate the game and and the players
need to legislate the game by how they
play and I don't know how long the game
took class so I know there are a lot of
injuries and serious injuries and and
and I'm not saying that's why but these
games are going way way way too long and
you know I'm not sure how TVs going to
be able to monitor this but I believe
they're going to lose their audience
when you
the Zebras all the time in meetings all
the time and discussions all the time
and you know Mike Pereira all the time
and you know I it's gotten out of
control the games too long and I'm
speaking as a quarterback and and I say
this when you get a rhythm going off
into lis and then you got a five or six
play drive going and all of a sudden you
got a review you know it breaks your
momentum you know you stand around for
five seven sometimes ten minutes while
these guys are reviewing the place it it
really slows down the tempo of the game
and you know last night I'm sitting at
watching as a fan on a kind of chair you
know and also you know you're watching a
game all sudden review and it looked
clearly look like pass interference I'm
saying okay that that's going to get
that's that's gonna be a penalty what
wasn't a penalty then there was one
later on Alshon Jeffery could you have
called that yeah you could have called
it and I agree with that
Aikman and Joe Buck were saying at least
they were consistent at least they're
consistently bad you know but you know I
think it's I don't like the rule I think
they got to tweak that rule we're
talking to Ron Jaworski I don't know if
you knew this Carson Wentz is the third
Eagles quarterback to throw at least
three touchdown passes in a victory over
the Packers at Lambeau joining Nick
Foles and Ron Jaworski 1979 Wow yeah I
don't remember that Dan yes you do glad
you mentioned my name though that's that
very kind of you guys we should that as
a quarterback matters not as an analyst
hey by the way you know that Lambeau
Field is absolutely spectacular and and
you know you have a magnificent
listening audience and I tell people if
you love football you need to go to
Lambeau Field put it on your bucket list
it is a great venue the fans are
fantastic and it's just a great place to
play football in that community I just
love Lambeau and I love when the NFL you
know televise those games and every
network does a great job of really
exposing the beauty of Green Bay and
Lambeau Field you completed eight passes
that day but three of the eight went for
touchdowns two went a harowin did we win
that's all that was the only time you
played at Lambeau I believe in your
career
I think I was there one time with the
Rams early in my career that was that
wasn't it when it was just a bowl then
when they didn't have all the you know
the fancy stuff around it and the locker
room you actually had to like walk
through the crowd to get to the locker
room
now that was nasty it was like I don't
remember old Tulane Stadium New Orleans
I mean they had concessionaires with
beer keg strapped on their backs you
know at that Stadium and the people were
laughs they were wasted and indeed to
walk from the locker room could sue
these fans that was football and you
know I brought this up I don't know if
it was last week or this week but where
did all the great nicknames go you were
the polish rifle like we don't have
great nicknames where we're like Carson
wins does he have a nickname yeah we
gotta give him a nickname you know I
mean then the Polish rifle went to jaws
you know so I don't know how that stuff
happens he's these sports writers try to
be very creative a couple of these cool
nicknames and you know I went from rifle
Ron at Youngstown State the Polish rifle
with the Rams and then two jaws with the
eagle so I don't know how this stuff
happens but you know Brady he wanted to
try to trademark Tom terrific and then
he was denied that I mean Brady just
he's like TV 12 you know well he is TV
12 but he's not Tom terrific that that
is Tom Seaver and III would disagree
with Tom Brady trying to trademark that
Tom Seaver well because I remember Tom C
and pitcher how great he was so he was
Tom terrific and he was Tom terrific
first do you think we're looking at a
200 million dollar quarterback and
Patrick mahomes is that out of the
question
no absolutely not as a salary cap keeps
increasing and the money in the game
keeps increasing you're gonna have in a
$200,000,000 quarterback in the near
future
it's funny Dan III used this is one of
my favorite stories you know I'm sorry
for getting carried away with stories
but in 1981 I was the highest-paid
player in the National Football League
I'm 1981 I'm the league MVP the Eagles
goes through both my contracts up Jimmy
and I agree to a new contract
highest-paid player in the league
$400,000 1981 what's that number about
38 million now I guess I missed my
mister by about 30 or 40 years
the increments were like 10,000 Bob
Griese went like 410 Archie Manning went
like 425 so I think you're gonna see a
$200,000,000 quarterback eventually yeah
I could see where it's a five-year deal
worth you know they're gonna average out
240 million dollars a year that does
that sound right for mahomes yeah it'll
come out to that and then the agent will
get out there well we'll all incentives
it'll be 50 million now how did
everybody mint not everybody but how did
most people miss on mahomes the same way
they miss on a lot of people you know
yeah I mean you never really know it's
it's classical you know every year
there's three or four guys people love
and there's three or four guys people
don't like it usually guys that they
don't love that seem to go to the NFL
and and and it and and nail it you know
because you can't look inside a person's
heart and know what goes on there you
don't know how he prepares themselves
you try you always try to do all the
research you can but I like Patrick
Holmes coming out but I did not see this
this type of talent he's got absolutely
incredible arm talent I mean this guy is
throwing you know 50-yard lasers that
are ten feet off the ground two on a
dime you know I mean he's an incredible
athlete and I will say this I've been
around Patrick he's one of the finest
most decent guys you'll find he's just a
good guy a personality and the guy you
love in the huddle you know the guy that
you want to be in the huddle with jaws
good to talk to you always love the
enthusiasm have a good weekend I will do
that I'm gonna play some golf yes that's
what I thought work on that nine point
five index thank you Ron Jaworski former
Eagles quarterback and former ESPN NFL
analyst for more Dan Patrick show tune
in to audience Channel 239 on DirecTV
stream for free on BR live or download
the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]